sun sand and sea
even in spring the turkish coastal city
of antalya offers everything a
vacationer's heart could desire
but tanya moskai is not in a holiday
mood
while her two children venture into the
water the ukrainian is thinking about
her homeland
when the war broke out she and her
children fled kiev for turkey via
romania
but even at the beach she still can't
relax
what bothers me is that i don't know
what kind of people are around me right
now
where do they come from
what did they think about my heritage
and my country
[Music]
because antalya is a popular destination
for tourists from russia the country
that has invaded her homeland ukraine
tanya knows that the majority of
russians support putin's policies
yet most of the russians at this beach
are reluctant to talk about the war
legends
we love our country our people and our
lives in russia
but we also understand what's happening
in ukraine
you can't blame us russians for that
many people just believe it when russian
tv claims that the ukrainian army is
attacking its own targets
before the war two million ukrainians
also vacationed on the turkish riviera
every year
now they're staying away
but turkish tour operators are hoping to
attract even more russian tourists
many here are glad that turkey is not
imposing sanctions on russia
in the future the russian market can
potentially supply 50 of all our
tourists
russia has assured us that up to 30
charter flights per day could soon be
arriving here
turkey is one of the last countries in
europe still fully open to russians
including oligarchs who moor their super
yachts here safe from sanctions
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
calls both ukraine and russia friends
he offered to mediate between the two
warring parties so far without success
tanya and her children are staying with
turkish friends
the two families got to know one another
before the war
we try to distract her so she doesn't
watch so much news
otherwise she won't stop crying
that's hard on me too
but distraction doesn't always work
tanya's husband is still in kiev helping
with the civil defense
i want to go back to my husband to my
homeland
but i'm afraid and i don't know how to
live with my fear
i hear stories about girls getting raped
many between 10 and 14 years of age
they're in hospital and quite a few are
pregnant
and so here in the hills above antalya
the ukrainian is caught up again and
again by the brutal war crimes in her
homeland
while russian tourists sun themselves on
the beaches below
you know i'm a very level-headed person
i avoid conflict and i hardly ever start
arguments
but seeing people from russia spending
their vacations here and having a good
time makes me pretty mad
tanya moskai would also have liked to
enjoy a relaxing family vacation in
antalya this year
but right now each visit to the beach is
a painful experience
you